ours is the fury these are the words of
the black stag of Baratheon a battle cry
echoed throughout the land in rebellion
when I Robert Baratheon the first of his
name seized the Iron Throne from the Mad
King Aerys Targaryen ending a dynasty
nearly 300 years old
House Baratheon was born in the wars of
conquest when Aegon the dragon invaded
Westeros Aegon sent his commander Horace
Baratheon to take storms end our
Galactica's the last of the storm kings
foolishly left the safety of his
stronghold and met the Baratheon warlord
in open battle Argyll a quiz soundly
defeated and Oris took his lands his
holdings and his daughter Horace was
said to be a half-brother to Aegon
Targaryen if this were true a little
blood of the Dragon mingled with that of
the stag in those days the seat of House
Baratheon is storm's end a legendary
keep raised in the Age of Heroes it
overlooks shipbreakers bay where legend
has it that durin the first storm king
raised the keep with the aid of bran the
Builder of House Stark forging a
centuries-long connection with the
Stormlands and the north after Aegon's
conquest of the Seven Kingdoms the
Baratheon's remained loyal enough to the
crown while Targaryen Kings came and
went but loyalty has its limits when
Rhaegar Targaryen
heiresses vile son and heir abducted
Lyanna Stark I betrothed my beloved it
was time to act
we raised our banners Baratheon stark
Jon Arryn and the Tully's United in
rebellion against Rhaegar and his father
the Mad King we were victorious and took
the Iron Throne that bit of Dragon blood
in my veins came in well as it made me a
distant relation to the Targaryen
dynasty blood of my long-lost ancestor
Horus the truth of it is I took it I sit
on the Iron Throne
I rule the Seven Kingdoms from the red
keep